ora guardiamo subito questo nel mio
reparto quindi e deve chiedere un mio
collega se lo trova chi sa di cosa ha
bisogno
aspirapolvere lo so ci provo cosa che
posso dire non ai fili quindi si cerca
un movente immagino
39 90 ma penda qual è l'offerta 13 euro
ma che vada butta in campo nord questo
cavo qua prossima come si chiama e mi
dice il nome 1 so come fare signora
sente dio da farsi ha bisogno di
qualcosa dal miur e papà io mi occupo di
pile no telefonino massimo o ricorda qua
la gente mi chiede cose che io non è dai
signora mio collegato mezz'ora fincher
pausa quindi aspettare o qui aprendo non
ce l'ha con il giro insomma
mi scuso